hi I'm Jess Finster Community director
and I'm here visiting Bethesda game
studios where the team is hard at work
on Starfield I just want to say how
grateful we all are for all of the
feedback support and questions that
you've been sharing with us on Reddit
Discord Twitter so we wanted to take a
moment to answer some of those questions
in our new series so let's get started
foreign
first thing that we want to know is what
inspired Starfield oh you know so many
things
um I think the main ones that I'm going
to go back like in time here
um Sundog is a big one amazing game kind
of like the science fiction game when
ultimas were out it also had this
partialist interface kind of one of the
first games where you're moving objects
around and putting them together but
great game where you had your own ship
and you could explore around uh that I
loved another one this is a kind of pen
and paper uh role-playing game at the
time where you know D D was getting
popular is this game traveler traveler
was a little more hard science fiction
the other thing there it's one of the
first games I programmed on the Apple II
at the time I really want to make a
traveler game it was also my first time
realizing that computers had memory that
you could run out of I can already see
the comments people saying you've been
running computers out of memory for 40
years now but that's an easy comment
everybody you can do better
um but but those are the big ones how
can you back to those those old
role-playing games that we loved and hey
can we pull off something like this with
today's computers and consoles and Etc
you mentioned a hard space
that I find I know that that's one of
the things that's been hotly debated in
the community is Starfield considered a
hard sci-fi I never quite know like
because that's always like what do they
think it is if you say yes or no I think
it is more hard to us hard hard science
fiction where you can draw that line
from okay here's what here's how man
explored space and you can like even
look at our ships and say all right that
has some you know visual identity back
to that but it's a trap question because
it's a video game right like a hard
science fiction video game would be you
die in space cold and a good example we
were really into Fuel and how the
gravity Drive works and like I'm reading
papers on like quantum physics and you
know bending space in front of you you
don't actually work you bend the space
you bring the space towards you and so
what we were playing that and became
like very punitive to the player your
shift would run out of fuel and the game
would just stop you just want to get
back to what you're doing so we've
recently changed it where the fuel in
your ship and the grav Drive limits how
far you could go at once but it doesn't
run out of fuel maybe there'll be an
update or a mod that allows that but
that's what we're doing now
constellation members are excited about
the character customization and the
trace in the game can you talk more
about what players will experience with
the traits I love our trait list it's
super fun
but each one obviously comes with some
sort of negative as well and we have a
way in the game kind of an activity or
Quest you can do to remove that trait as
opposed to don't like my character I
want to start over each of them are
something like that you can solve that
removes the entire trait for the rest of
your playthrough the last question we
have speech checks and dialogue that
reflect your character build do you want
to expand upon that yeah look we've done
a lot of different dialogue systems and
you've gone back to kind of I'll call it
like a classic Bethesda style dialogue
with you're looking at the character and
how they emote you have a series of
choices there the scope of the game the
amount of content we're making is a bit
more than we've done before in terms of
quests and things like that but the
depth in some of the stuff with the
dialogue we just passed 250 000 lines
and so that's a lot of dialogue but
we've gone through it and the impact is
really there and that includes my
favorite speech persuasion system you're
not talking us out of this score it
feels like it's part of the dialogue but
you're spending points to persuade them
you willing to give up the ship
it's like that it feels natural not like
I've entered some other mode where we're
not I'm not doing regular dialogues I'm
in this mode of persuading you to get
what I want having a way with words
might prove useful that's it that's all
the questions that I have for today yeah
this has been great you know everybody
out there you know keep it coming we do
really read it all and also we look
forward to showing you more of the game
in the future as well
thanks everyone for tuning in that's all
we have for today but don't forget you
can submit your questions at the hashtag
below see you later
[Music]